[Music]
[Music] I
chose blue.
When I was young, I was a foreign language college and there was
night
blue, so I was tempted to go with light blue.
But that feeling was why I chose black.
Yes, I have five colors.
[Music]
If I had to come in, it would be shopping.
[Music] I
think I'm a bit sensitive to the sensibility.
Are you a respawn thief? I'll
take full responsibility until the end.
[Music]
Kimchi stew is surprisingly
not that difficult for you, either.  Why is it that there is no kimchi and
red pepper powder is
not that difficult?
[Applause] What about
other members like this?
In the restaurant, it's
Kalbig Kal. On the
phone,
Tteokbokki is Tteokbokki
[Music]
New Kit is so good these days that I just
put in a little bit of it and it's
the best kimchi stew.  Since there is also, just
heat it in the microwave and you will
get amazing kimchi right away.
Ah, first of all, I want to choose everyone here.
It
's Minhyuk [music].
It's the same. [
Laughs] I
wanted to communicate comfortably with foreigners, so a
member
appeared.You
both.  It's mine,
I came out
[Music]
[Laughter]